now got some breaking news to bring you
on sky news
this afternoon in that uh the queen and
the duke of edinburgh
have received their coronavirus
vaccinations
joining we're told more than a million
people now who have been given
the job boris johnson of course said
yesterday around one and a half
million now isn't it uh this is a highly
unusual move
by buckingham palace which has commented
on private health matters of the queen
and
prince philip let's join our royal
correspondent rhiannon mills
on the line now uh afternoon to you uh
rhiannon and
as i say that quite unusual move from
the palace
oh it is it's incredibly unusual usually
when it comes to
medical matters the palace normally say
to us no comment
and certainly ever since we knew that
the vaccine was here in the uk
uh the palace have said that this was a
private matter um
when exactly that the couple would
receive the vaccination
but they have today confirmed that both
the queen
and the duke of edinburgh have today
received their covid 19
vaccinations it's also been confirmed to
me that these were administered by a
household
doctor at windsor castle
and also when asked well why are you
telling us this now
i understand from the palace that they
wanted to prevent inaccuracies
and further speculation about when
exactly they were going to be inoculated
and actually it was her majesty the
queen who decided that she would let it
be known that she has had
the vaccination of course it was
inevitable
that as a couple they would receive the
vaccine
in the early stages of it being rolled
out across the country
the queen of course 94 years old the
duke of edinburgh
99 years old and everything possible has
been done to try
and shield them protect them from the
virus
remember ever since march uh when we've
of course for all starting to get used
to the covert 19 restrictions
uh coming into into place the queen
moved from buckingham palace
to windsor castle the duke of edinburgh
who's been spending so much time in
norfolk
also went to windsor castle and really
pretty much
throughout last year they spent the
majority of their time apart from a
short
time uh in scotland over the summer they
have
primarily been there based at winter
castle and shielded from as many people
as possible so for example when the
queen has given her
her national addresses when she's
recorded things like the christmas
broadcast
only very small numbers of people have
been allowed near her to try and protect
her
from the virus but yes it is fascinating
that this afternoon the palace
and specifically her majesty the queen
have decided to
announce uh that they have both received
the vaccination
of course they were always going to get
the vaccination weren't they
both of them being in the priority group
the highest priority group over 90.
that's right but i think as we said
before when it com
comes to medical matters for example in
the past few years when
uh prince philip has been treated in
hospital
um the palace have always been very keen
to
keep the details that they've given us
to the the minimum
and so i think it is significant that
the palace
and the queen have decided that they
would confirm today that they have
uh received the vaccination there was
speculation in some of the newspapers a
couple of weeks ago
um i have to say primarily i think
coming
from sort of political side that the
queen
would make it be known when she'd had
the vaccination
of course for those within number 10 and
also within the health service
it's significant it's important to see
that her majesty the queen has said yes
i will have this vaccination and right
throughout this pandemic
that the royal family have been very
much
setting the example to the rest of the
country uh when it comes to
how they've been carrying out their work
so making sure they're wearing face
masks at the right time
the queen very early on wearing gloves
when people are still
allowed to to meet with her and also
making sure that they don't break any of
the the restrictions so
any kind of public engagements have been
had to be scrapped
uh certainly during those lockdown
periods and instead the queen having to
adapt like the rest of us
to working from home and getting used to
carrying out virtual engagements
instead it's worth saying that actually
back in in 1957 the queen
broke with protocol when she told the
country that
prince charles and princess anne who
were eight and six at the time had been
inoculated
uh against polio and at the time that
was to try and allay any
sort of public concerns about the
potential side effects of that vaccine
so i think it is a very powerful message
today that the queen is saying yes i've
had the vaccine yes my 99 year old
husband has also had the vaccine
when it comes to that public service
messaging saying look the vaccine
is needed it's safe if we are going to
get through
uh this third lockdown and this
this wave of the the pandemic that we're
still facing
remind us quite naturally we haven't
seen the queen for some time she
and prince philip are sheltering aren't
they at windsor castle
famously they weren't at their
traditional christmas gathering at
sandringham of course
that's right like the rest of us all of
their their arrangements
have have had to change over over the
last 12 months whether that comes to
working or when that comes to
meeting up with the family and as you
said the usual christmas
gathering at sandringham that had to be
scrapped instead
the queen and prince philip spent
christmas
alone together and within her christmas
message
um she delivered that message simply
with a picture of prince philip
alongside her which i think was kind of
sending that message that we were all
having to
deal with um being away from from our
loved ones
at this time yeah and yeah now that we
are in
to this third national lockdown again
the royal family
are going to continue to do what they
can to
to set the example and i think try and
celebrate the hard work that's going on
right across the country for example
yesterday uh prince william spoke to nhs
staff at
homerton uh university hospital in
hackney
and he heard for himself the horrors
that some of those nhs staff are facing
at the moment the tiredness
the anxiety that they're going through
and actually prince william said
to those nhs staff that both him and
kate have been talking to their three
young children
about the work that's going on within
the nhs and the sacrifices that are
having to be made by so many people
at this incredibly difficult time